Uh, okay. Let's talk next about some notable
stories that the David Pakman show subreddit,
the David Pakman show subreddit now has more
than 16,000 of our viewers and listeners subscribed.
You can discuss topics from the show or other
topics of political interest with other viewers
and listeners. There are moderators. Things
are kept under control. Don't worry about
trolling David pakman.com/reddit is the place
one, uh, discussion I wanted to address was
posted this morning or a few days ago, actually
not this morning. And it, the question is,
will David endorse or at least disclose the
candidate he supports? A caller today asked
who David would vote for if the primary word
today, and he responded with either Bernie
or Warren. But will David make either a formal
endorsement or at least an official announcement
of who he intends to vote for? So I've gotten
a lot of emails from people who say they want
me to disclose, uh, to make an endorsement
soon. And others who say, David, you've made
clear that you are a Bernie Warren guy. Uh,
it doesn't really make sense to, um, throw
in who you're going to vote for at this early
stage.
It's better for you to just keep reporting
on policy and whatever. Here's my plan. I
am going to tell you who I support in the
primary here in the state of Massachusetts.
Now I want to be transparent. I expect that
by the time I vote in Massachusetts, we will
know whether Bernie or Warren, uh, which of
the two, if either has a shot at securing
the nomination. So I don't think that it is
going to be a crucial moment at that point
anymore. But quite frankly, the reason I'm
not saying who I'm going to vote for is I
don't know. I'm a Bernie Warren guy. There
are lots of reasons why I more in line with
Bernie than Elizabeth Warren. I have some
concerns about some of the elements in Bernie's
campaign. And I also think about, uh, what
is most likely to be made policy. There's
a pragmatic element.
These are not attacks on either candidate.
I don't actually know who it is that I'm going
to vote for here in Massachusetts, but I will
tell you, rest assured, another post from
the David Pakman show subreddit Dave Rubin.
I am now pro-life. Yes. So there's a cultural
critic and arbiter of ideas named Dave Rubin
who interviews people from all over the political
spectrum, mostly right-wingers. And he uh,
has talked about how he didn't leave the left,
the left left him, but his views have actually
been changing. And the latest in this evolution
is that, uh, he, um, now says that he is no
longer an atheist. And I saw a video where
he said he's still mostly secular but believes
there's something bigger. And it seemed like
a way to basically ride the fence so that
you don't have to in a completely embarrassing
way, say my view has changed 180 degrees,
which for a 40 year old, to have that kind
of awakening is, is odd, is to say the least.
But he claims he's had it fine. He's found
a way to ride the fence, which is to say he's
still mostly secular, but he now believes
that there is something bigger and that it
seems like it will kind of placate the, the
right wing religious folks that increasingly
follow him. And so the prediction here from
this user on our subreddit is Dave Ruben will
eventually come out as pro-life and being
against abortion wouldn't be surprised if
it'd be funny or if he came out and said he
was no longer gay, that that actually would
be more of an awakening. Um, but I don't expect
that to happen and I, uh, would not be shocked
if he comes out and says he is now pro-life.
Also from the David Pakman show, sub Reddit.
Um, Pete Buddha judge releases a list of McKinsey
clients and that list includes blue cross,
blue cross blue shield of Michigan and the
department of defense.
So listen, I've already said that. Uh, Pete
would, and judge is not a progressive. He's
really a Biden centrist. That's what he is.
He's not been hiding it. His views on campaign
finance reform are not particularly progressive.
We had video of that for you earlier this
week. I think that it's perfectly fine to
say part of P Buddha judge not being a progressive
is that he wants consulted for the department
of defense. What is less progressive than
that or for an insurance company. But I actually
don't think these are the strongest arguments
against P Buddha judge. In the same way that,
you know, we talked earlier this week how
there are people going after Elizabeth Warren
because she consulted with a lot of different
companies, um, over a 30 year period, earning
one point $9 million over those 30 years.
And there are people saying, well, this client
was not good or that client was not good lawyers,
consultants.
I mean, I'm not defending them, but you don't
always love every client that you're working
with. Maybe he does love the department of
defense or those insurance companies. I don't
know. But there are so many other reasons
not to support [inaudible] didn't judge that.
I don't know that it's necessary to go down
this path. If you disagree, let me know. Join
the discussion on the David Pakman show subreddit@davidpakman.com
slash R E D D I. T.